well I wish there was something really
funny there's um sorry good good good
good
I don't know if how we met is that funny
or amusing but we were all just
performing at UCB theatre Upright
Citizens Brigade here in New York and
now Paul and I have known each other for
about 10 years and had done a lot of
improvising and sketch shows together
and the Z's was doing stand-up and so we
were all kind of he knew who we were and
we knew who he was and it was just sort
of this mutual admiration society and as
he started doing the show every week
called crash-test and it was like a
stand-up show and he kind of wanted
people to co-host it with him so the
first week he asked me and and we we did
a sketch on stage called shudder bugs
which was about we basically had I had
all these kids headshots different don't
ask why and I had all these headshots of
little kids and we did this bit on stage
where we were like headshot
photographers and we basically just
criticized these headshots of these
adorable little kids and just like rip
these kids apart and then that sort of
created this sketch that we eventually
did called shudder bugs where we sort of
changed it so we became talent agents
for little kids so that's how kind of we
met like just doing bits on stage and
doing videos and then he and Paul
co-hosted in subsequent weeks and they
did a video and a bit on stage about
kind of making fun of shitty magicians
and stuff and they did this bit called
illusion aiders which is vaguely
inspired by Criss Angel and and so
that's sort of where you know to kind of
popular sketches of ours came from just
kind of doing bits on stage they used to
be really
when people even talk about like those
other groups we're actually super
flattered to even be compared to any of
them I mean we have a lot of fun too or
doing and try to do really funny stuff
but yeah I mean they're amazing sketch
groups in the pantheon of sketch history
and yeah I mean that's always like
really flattering to be compared to any
of those guys we just want to like we
just want to keep doing our thing and
and and we really don't care about
anything else but just like making funny
stuff you know like we don't worry about
what's coming up down the road or
anything like that and we try you know
they're the great thing about like the
the comedy world right now is that um
there's just like a really good feel
like it's a really good time for comedy
you know there's just a lot of cool
stuff going on and people are doing you
know especially in New York for sure
like we're just doing like really smart
different funny stuff and you know we're
glad to be in the mix and and what's
cool about it is that there's also like
this sort of really supportive community
and like no one ever shits on anybody
else you know you don't ever hear people
like just attacking other people it's
all like it seems like there's a lot of
like there's a bug in here man what the
the it's just kind of a cool community
right now there seems to be like a lot
of just admiration for different people
doing different stuff whether it's
stand-up or sketch or improv or whatever
like just seems to be like a really
supportive cool thing and I mean for
example you know we were able to get
some guys from SNL to do some bits in
our show like Andy Samberg and Fred
Armisen and Bill Hader and you know they
that we've known those guys for a while
and but they just really liked the show
and we were like but you guys are
already on a really great show it's a
very famous sketch comedy show you know
there's like yeah but it'd be fun to do
your show you know so that's just kind
of cool there's no like you know no
one's knowing fights or whatever it's
just kind of cool to pop up and other
people's projects